يا لي على الكرسي الله يعينه ما بيشوف يا
حرام اطرش واخرس مو فهمان شو عم يصير
حواليك ليكو هدول المعاقين ابصر هالعيله
شو عامله لربها حتى بلاها بهيك ولد معاق
شو اخده معي استحي فيه قدام العالم وين
بدي اوشي من العالم والله شو يسوي
[تصفيق]
ولد مو بسمعه توحد لا وكمان فرط نشاط
خلينا نكون واقعيين انه اغلبنا سمعنا او
حكينا
الكلمات والزمن الاساسي مو بس نحن السبب
فيه سببه عدم وعين مجتمع وعائلات وافراد
زرعوا فينا انه هدول الاشخاص عيب وشيء
[موسيقى]
لازم نخبيه وما حدا يعرف عنه شيء انا منعم
عمري 32 سنه بعد كل يوم رح طبق 33 بعرف مو
مبين علي لهيك خلوا الموضوع بيناتنا بشتغل
باحد الشركات الخاصه بدمشق بقسم خدمه الزب
ائن هو من جديد صرت بقسم الاتش ار مؤسس
احد اهم المبادرات لدعمنا نحنا يلي بينقال
عنا معاق
طالبه جامعيه بجامعه دمشق بعد ما تخرجت
يمكن لان لسه ما لقيت حالي بالمكان اللي
ممكن ابدا فيه وحاليا عم فكر بالاعلام
معي شويه شهادات محليه ودوليه قصائد
الاعمال التطوعيه والانسانيه ما بينحكى
فيهم بس بالنسبه لالي شي كتير عظيم وهلا
خلينا ذوي الاعاقه او معاقين او دعاءات
وكثير من المصطلحات وكل حدا منا بيحكي على
حسب ادراكهم ونظرتو لهاي الفئه من المجتمع
مثل ما بنعرف انه التعريف من دول للامم
المتحده هو ذوي الاعاقه مثل ما تم تعريفه
انه هنن الاشخاص اللي بيعانوا من مشاكل
ذهنيه او حسيه او عقليه
ممكن للمشاركه بصوره كامله وفعاله
بالمجتمع مع الاخرين بس بالاعاقه عندي هي
الزرافه واراده قويه لحتى اوصل لحلمي
واثبت وجودي بمجتمع لسه بده شويه شغل
ليشوفنا من الزاويه الصح لهيك حبينا
نغيرها المصطلح ونقول اصحاب الهمم بس ولكن
اذا تجرات ان تكون مختلفه ما عليك الا ان
تكون مستعدا للمواجهه ومعلش شو خسرانين
اذا حكينا هاي الكلمات اللي ممكن تحفز
الطرف الثاني وصدقوني هي كلمه سلسله وقويه
ومحفزه وقريبه من الالم مثل محسوبتكم وهلا
بدي احكي لكم قصه راشد
راشد بسبب خطا طبي صار عنده شلل رباعي
وبقيه اربع سنين ببيته منعزل عن الحياه
واهله لا حول لهم ولا قوه وحدا من الناس
يلي بحبوا راجل خبرونا عنه
احنا بفريقنا التطوعي اللي فيه اشخاص من
اصحاب وغير اصحاب الهمام نتعرف على راشد
وفعلا تعرفنا عليه وخبرنا انه هو شخص قادر
يكون منتج بالمجتمع وباثر هاي الكلمات بعد
فتره زمنيه راشد صار ينزل يحضر دوراتنا
التدريبيه بمساعده فريقنا التطوعي وبعد
فتره اخذ البكالوريا وهلا هو طالب جامعه
وبيعزل وبيحضر محاضراته مع اصدقائه يلي في
منهن اشخاص من فريقنا نفسه
وكمان بدي احكي لكم قصه تانيه هي قصه
الخطابه في عنا عاده بالشام كلياتنا
بنعرفها وهي عاده الخطابه وانه بكل جامعه
نساء او زيارات بينهم في وحده بتكون عم
بتزل على صبايا للخطبه ومره كنت طالبه
بكالوريا وكنت باحد هاي الزياره بتكون في
وحده عم تدل على صبايا للخطبه بتقوم تلتفت
علي وبتقول لي ما تواخذيني ما فينا ندل
عليك ولا نحكي عنك الله يكون بعونك ويعلي
مراتبك ونصيبك بتجنن لالك معاقه وطبعا
بنخجل نحكي عنك عن المحيط والناس يلي
حوالينا بلحظتها سالت مع نفسي
هل نحن كاصحاب الهمم ما بنمتلك مشاعر او
نفس بشريه لها حق بالارتباك او الزواج بس
لسانيا كان في صوت كتير عظيم قدامي عم
يحكي هو جاوب هاي الخطابه ويقول لها
انت مو اكرم من الله وانا شايفه منى بمكان
كتير كبير وفي مستقبل كبير ناطره
هذا الصوت هو صوت ام عظيمه جابتني على هاي
الدنيا يلي لما ولدت الدكاتره قالوا لا ما
بتعيش غير سنه شبعوا منها بس انا عشرت
وكملت ولكن
كتير كنت بتمنى وجود هاي الانسانه معنا
اليوم ولكن شاء رب العالمين اني افقدها هي
ووالدي من سنين وكل مسؤوله عن نفسي وعن
حياتي بكل تفاصيلها بس ما هيك عم كمل مثل
ما كانت تقول دايما اني انا راح اوصل
والحمد لله وصلت
لهيك رح نتفق مع بعض انه الكلمه الحلوه
صدقه شو خسرانه اذا حكينا كلمه جميله بحق
الاشخاص يلي مقابلنا لان نحنا باثر كلمه
وحده ممكن يمتلي عقلها وتتغذى روحك باثر
هاي الكلمات لان الكلمه بتفرق
ولان الكلمه بتفرق
بدي اقول للاهل انتم الداعم الاول والاخير
اذا كان عندكم شخص من اصحاب الهمم ادعموه
وقوه ووقفوا جنبه ابدا ما تخجلوا فيه
وتحسسوه انه هو عنده نقص بالعكس بشتغلوا
فيه لان انتم الدرجه الاولى يلي بده يطلع
عليها على الحياه
بالمقابل ما رح نكون عاطفيين زياده وانه
هو حرام وما بيصير وعنده رقص وما لازم لا
خلينا نكون حكيمين للتصرف والتعامل لحتى
قبلنا يوصل للمكان اللي هو حابب يوصل له
وكمان بدي اقول للمجتمع نحن بحاجه لنشر
وعي اكثر عن اصحاب الهمم ونغير مفهوم ما
الك مكان بيننا
لا لك مكان بس ادواتك هي اللي
بتختلف يعني بدل ما تحكي بصوتك رح تحكي
بلغه الاشاره وبدل ما تحكي
على كرسي بعجله لهيك واجبي انا وانت وكل
حدا مسؤول انه نغير هاي النظره عن الاشخاص
من اصحاب اللي هي ما وخلينا متاكدين انه
رسالتك غير رسالتي ويمكن رسالتي كانت
محمله بالصبر اكثر مدرسه بس مع هيك بيقدر
نغير مجتمعنا لحتى يصير افضل وهلا بدي
اقول لاصدقائي من اصحاب الهمم يلي عم بحكي
عن ربع السكان بعد 12 سنه من الازمه انا
مالي جايه اقول لك انه الحياه ورديه
وخصوصا هون في تحديات وعقبات وصعوبات
وشغلات كثير رح يتواجد ممكن تبكي كثير او
ممكن تنجرح من اقرب الناس الى بس انت راح
تكون قدها ونحن متل ما بنعرف وحسب
الدراسات عنا حساسيه وهذا الشيء من رب
العالمين ماله من عنا بس انت رح تقدر
وتوصل لحلمك وتاثبت وجودك برغم اي صعوبات
ممكن تواجهها
وختاما بدي اقول شكرا لاي منصه بتسمح لنا
نوصل صوتنا بطريقه صح بعيدا عن الشفقه
اليوم انا هنا عم قيق وقفت قدامكم على
منصه بكره
من اصحاب الهمم لحتى يكون صوتهم مسموع
ويكونوا جزء من تنميه المجتمع ابدا مو
عائق فيه واليوم كلياتنا رح نطلع من هاي
القاعه ونكون رح نغير وتفرق معنا الكلمات
ونبدل ذوي الاعاقه لاصحاب الهمم لانه
الكلمهن بتفرق وشكرا
[تصفيق]